[Music]
when Tom Hanks was in your video that
was amazing I'm pregnant
okay just kidding
[Music]
any movie star you want to like get in
another video I dream way too thick
you'll never happen Meryl Streep come be
mine oh yes yes you have worked with so
many people any dream collaborations you
still want to make happen so many I mean
the world is full of just so many
creative people and I think my favorite
thing is a really unique collaboration I
recently fell in love with the van both
tech and actually did reach out to them
and got to work with him this week so I
feel like some of those dreams are
coming true and I hope I can keep kind
of brainstorming other fun
collaborations like that now we're very
excited for your new music we were just
on the spot of your music video and then
you're going on tour Katy Perry it's
nice and um I obviously have said there
are some production delays how did you
find out about that or do you know what
might be going on there in terms of one
we can see it all happen no I'm in the
dark but I'm sure though the wait will
be well worth it
[Music]